2020 has not been many people's year but
i think it actually has been your year
you've made the most of this crazy time
bananas
it's absolutely bananas so great to talk
to you i mean i
started a podcast and we now just hit
over 200 000 downloads
i've uh became a co-host of the real i
mean that's amazing
and you know a few things here and there
all right well can we set the record
straight
are you returning to the real housewives
i am returning to the housewives
yes you say that with a little bit of a
laugh how you feeling
you gotta be a little you know a little
brave a little scared a little
ready i mean it's all those things and
uh i say it with the lab
because i'm ready but you're never
really ready
well and you know the sophomore season
is kind of the scary one that's
sometimes the one where
stuff goes down that's right that's what
i'm afraid of
so here we go you know and i sort of got
a warning from
you know miss rinna and uh so we'll see
i'm ready though bring it you got the
big exclusive on the reel you got
denise's exit interview
what really made you decide not to come
back next season
it was actually a really tough decision
you know i went back and forth with it
and at the end of the day i decided it
was time for me to move on and
you know focus on uh other projects that
i have
how do you feel about where things left
off with denise
you know i'm sad about it i really wish
you wouldn't you know leave the
franchise i think she's great i think
she brings a lot i think the fans
obviously love her and root for her so
i'm really sad about it i wish there was
something that could have been done
i'm gonna miss her but obviously i'm
gonna miss her on the platform but
we always talk maybe she'll be willing
to shoot like a little dinner scene or
something with you we can get our little
drive by
denise check in i would love that and i
think she'd be up for that so we'll see
what did you make of how the cast
reacted to the news cause i i thought it
was interesting that it was like
gifts and memes i was actually shocked i
was really shocked by the means and i
thought that they were really mean i
mean it's one thing
to be on the show and have your feelings
but for her to say i'm leaving the
franchise i think at that point
you gotta level up and you gotta say you
know
good luck denise we wish you were i mean
just something kind
you know the person who really came for
denise the most in those
reunion episodes was renault if you
wanna play this game we can do it
are you threatening me all you do is
attack her every time you see her
she's also your friend so where do you
and rena go from here
i don't really know honestly and i won't
know until i
see her and we either talk it out or we
don't um
but it really left a bad taste in my
mouth if i'm going to be honest which i
normally am
something that really stuck to me that
you told me when we talked all those
months ago was
you realize the rina in housewives was
different
than the rinna you knew outside of
housewives
and i'm sticking by it how is she
different
the arena that i knew before housewives
is really who i could speak to
you know she was fun she was supportive
she was nice she was kind
and i get it we're shooting a tv show
and i get drama as a part of it
but i think she took it to a level that
um
was not a good look she posted a message
to instagram that was like tell bravo
you want us to have fun again to get
back to the lighthearted stuff
and to me i'm like well aren't you guys
in control of kind of the attitude you
bring
to the table no one's telling you how to
i didn't see that but i heard that she
did that
um yeah i don't know where that's coming
from the other exit
teddy mellencamp will not be returning
to the group i recently found
out that my contract as a housewife is
not being renewed um of course i could
give you the standard response of
oh we both came to the decision that it
would be best
yeah i'm not gonna do that that's not
who i am how do you feel about that
okay just some dead air there and then
okay okay
okay i'll take it i'll take it okay that
will change the dynamic for everyone and
kyle because kyle's little buddy will be
gone and obviously you and kyle have
some work to do
i love that you said little buddy you
and kyle have some work to do
do you have any idea how that's gonna go
no i have no idea how that's gonna go
but that's really important to me that
her and i sit down
right away and hash it out and just or
talk it through
however you wanna put it i like hash it
out
what do you make of uh the reports that
kathy hilton her sister might be coming
around a little bit
um i met kathy at a few dinners
um she seems like a lovely lady i think
that's an ally obviously for kyle and
you know
the more the merrier i mean come on i
don't want to throw shade i don't i
haven't spent time with her let me spend
time with her and we'll go from there
there it is well you know everyone loved
seeing you spend time with your
girlfriends i think your actual
kind of poor group of girls will we see
any of them
next season i hope so yeah the response
has been
incredible and when we're together it's
so much fun and there's no
there's no like we're not trying to you
know shade each other or anything like
that if we do it's out of fun
so i would love to see more of that and
i think bravo does too i think everyone
would like to see more of that you've
been part of the call for
diversity i think the audience is ready
for more diversity there's a name
floating around crystal minkoff might be
joining who would be the show's first
asian
cast member oh i don't know her you
might meet her
in the next few weeks garcelle i
probably will you know more than i do
you're always at the t
always i had to dig in a little bit
i love that you saw the first episode
before i did
this is true well let's dig into the new
job with the real
ladies we have so much to talk about
today i just want to jump into the girl
chat are you good with that
how'd the job come your way how did this
land on your lap
you know what's so funny i was at home
and i was watching
tv one of the entertainment shows
probably yours and uh
and they said that uh tamara was leaving
the reel and i was like oh that's too
bad
and it didn't like a light bulb didn't
even go off for me because i figured
okay i'm busy already right
and then my good friend john murray
called me and he goes are you throwing
your hat in the ring and i was like
oh i really hadn't thought about it he's
like are you crazy
and then i was like you're right i am
crazy
and so then we started the process and i
tested with a bunch of you know
different women
and who all were capable of doing the
job but i am thrilled that i was the
chosen one
it's been now a few weeks you've been at
it how's it been so far one thing is
that's really great the commute is
awesome
you're there you're in the office right
now this is yours right here
it's been really fun i mean we're sit i
mean the girls and i are just seamless
that's seamless that's effortless it's a
lot of fun
a lot of technical difficulties because
we're all doing it from home it's also
different
but i think we have a really great
groove
and i'm beyond excited about it have you
learned anything about yourself in these
first couple weeks doing the show
i have to learn to take my you know wake
my turn because we're all talking at the
same time but it's been great i mean
they were so welcoming
and uh it's a fun group it's really a
great group
what have you learned about your
co-hosts in these early weeks that
surprised you
lonnie is not a morning person at all
we'll have our morning meeting and she's
like and i actually texted her i'm like
girl are you okay she's like yeah i'm
just not a morning person
i kind of love that you had amanda seals
on the podcast
as the changing of the guard was
happening with the real and her advice
to you was simply
good luck which i thought was kind of
wild and ominous yeah i was like that's
it
this podcast is intended for a mature
audience as it contains
adult language and can get rather
intimate so
grab a cocktail find a safe place to
listen and make sure your kids aren't
around
so going to bed with garcelle i love the
message at the beginning of the podcast
that's essentially like a warning if you
put this on in your car with your kids
in the back seat turn it off
do it don't do it the jamie foxx
chat really blew up that caught a lot of
attention
it sure did a lot more than we thought i
know you had the conversation in the
podcast but then the conversation
continued on the reel did you hear from
jamie after you discussed his manhood on
the reel
no he said how we gonna be together he
hung like a horse
i was like what's wrong with that so
i just want to know garcelle what's
going on
look at genie
he knew because we talked about it on
the podcast and he was so
funny i mean you know obviously it's not
a bad thing right
no i think it's you're basically saying
i don't want it but ladies
it is yours for the taking and i'm at it
i'm at it
he's a good sport the podcast it seems
like you just hit the ground running and
it is
taking off and listen sometimes i wake
up in the middle of the night
you know going oh my god i can't believe
i revealed so much what am i doing but
it's really fun and i think
you know everybody who leaves the show
has a great time not trying to get
anybody to say anything that they
wouldn't want to say
so it's just pure fun pure adult fun
which of the housewives would you most
want to have on oh who do i think would
be more open
probably erica but i wouldn't mind
hearing from dorit either i don't think
i'd get anything out of sutton
[Laughter]
it would it might be interesting to have
all three of them on at one time but you
would have to film the video just to see
what sutton's reactions would be
absolutely that's a great idea that's a
great idea did he take your virginity
why you want to go there because you
know what you're doing
that is wrong
all right gonna pivot now to coming to
america
to america is one of the few movies that
has not been moved off the schedule it's
still on the schedule for this year
what was it like to revisit essentially
your first project
good morning your highness
it was tremendous we were all giddy
we were happy to be there it's obviously
nostalgic
i think you'll be surprised by who is
added you know to the cast and where the
storyline goes but then
it's going to be visually stunning and i
just pray we're in theaters by then
me too it would be a holiday miracle
nice little holiday surprise
if we can get to the theater around that
time of year right to wrap things up
here
are there any guests you can tease on
either the podcast or the real coming up
that you're excited about oh the podcast
who do we have coming up
i think we may be getting eve which
would be amazing very exciting and eve
you guys could uh
swap talk show stories oh wouldn't that
be great
and the demise of marie osmond on the
show yeah
you got to get to the bottom of that
because we still don't know what
happened there yeah
yeah tricky all right well good catching
up with you i can't
wait for your next season of beverly
hills i think you guys are filming soon
maybe some filming already started
but yes love that the reel will keep you
in la so you probably won't be traveling
as much you'll get to show up to more
stuff maybe cause a little more drama
that's exactly right that's exactly
[Music]
right
you